because I don't know if you guys seen
sex robbers lately they look crazy they
look crazy I haven't checked them out
lately I like the one I have at home
it's really nice let's try some out yeah
[Music]
uh who's familiar with what's going on
with the writer's strike right now oh my
God
I hear all my clients talk about the
strikes I just saw it like I didn't
realize it but a big part of why they
won't sign the contract is the AI stuff
oh that's what I heard no clue that
that's part like the biggest part yeah
definitely yeah it's one of the biggest
Parts in terms of like writers wanting
to protect their creative like
involvement with certain things because
now they they do feel threatened that
they can be replaced with something like
a Chad gbt to like kind of just you know
write new episodes for different
concepts and whatnot that are pulling
from the intellectual kind of property
and Creations of former artists former
writers you know what I'm saying so yeah
that's what Chad GBC is getting anyway
it's pulling from all the stuff that
real artists and people have already
done but it's easy and it works and it's
cheap so they're basically just trying
to fight for
guaranteed things like uh better pay
better like uh you know longer periods
of like work that's guaranteed where
it's like if I'm contracted onto this
show it's a set amount of like time that
I'm supposed to be like working on the
project so that they have like Clarity
on it on the work I'm just trying to be
a migrant worker for the writers we got
four feature films written I don't need
to pay be paid [__] union fees or any
of that [__] just make our movie like
how can I get under the table and be the
Home Depot writer yeah
why they're on strike hire me I'll write
your next [__] movie
I bet actually a lot of people
we got [__] four movies or [__]
sick
and they're just the scary thing is like
going on strike doesn't that sort of
encourage the use of AI
yeah isn't that kind of like at least at
least like I'm not saying that like
that's what it should be but like in the
evidence of History like the like the
great Car Wash Union that they tried to
start and that encouraged the use of
automated car washes and it's just like
every time that happens where they push
it to a point it's like more towards the
side of yeah you know well in this
situation uh because of it um Seth
MacFarlane actually quit Family Guy amid
the Hollywood Riders strike two he did
huh so like what happens though when you
get like big and key players in there
especially a guy like did you hire the
Home Depot writers
conceptualizing creating writing and
voice acting multiple character you know
what I mean so it's like there's that's
a big quit yeah we're not playing that
much of a role I wonder what the
longevity of AI is in the form of like
writing entertainment you know what I
mean like is it do you think it's going
to last do you think it'll be actually
pretty good do you think it's going to
be one of those things where we could
see the formula that's being played out
in TV shows because we could already see
that now with like regular writers but
do you think it would be it would get
worse with AI or do you think it'll be
just I honestly don't think it'll get
worse that's the scary that's the reason
because if it was if AI was that
unreliable it wouldn't be that big of a
thing on the table writers just go go
ahead and use your crappy ass AI but
it's not going to be crappy that's the
scary part yeah and also what I think
too is
um like the whole like consuming the art
it's a relationship with the artist and
the person consuming the art
so like I I don't think AI can get as
good as like like the most genius
artists because some of those things are
in the moment inspiration just two like
synapses that happen like even if you're
like doing stand-up comedy whatever you
could do your same set every single time
and then you're just inspired to say a
different slightly different punch line
and you switch that word out and boom it
[__] hits and it kills even with
music or whatever but I the scary part
is I don't think consumers demand that
high of quality that's true especially
now so I think consumers they just want
like give me anything just give me
liberty give me anything right and so
like I think AI can give them every
single time and AI is telling them that
consumers don't demand that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's true here's a
diabolical thought is you know how they
map all the human DNA like all the
combination of the possibilities yeah
you know there's some dirt out there
that's not funny that has no
storytelling ability is could map out
all the possible stories or like a large
chunk all the possible jokes put it
online and any comic any writer that has
me hey you know what you're copying me
because you can't prove that they didn't
read it or they didn't see it and that's
why I think it becomes problematic that
is crazy it's a good idea because you
know those YouTube Comedians and
Tick-Tock comedians that will word for
word copy a comedian and deny it yeah
and then when they get when they finally
they relent they go oh I was paying
homage to them right meanwhile they
never said who who they got it from like
where they got it but if AI is doing
this
like what's what's to stop and just
mapping out every combination of words
yeah
um conversation that we had there
because that you know because like all
it is is combinations of words like Bart
you were saying like one word hit and
just boom well they if they already
mapped out all the possible words
and if they put it out there and then
someone's making like a million dollars
from doing the performance like hey you
know what I like no I put this out here
I had it on this blog I wrote this out
they copied I deserve some of that money
like will they win I have no idea but
that's kind of like to me is what the
threat of AI That's like that's like
also um you know how like you can take
an image of something change it a
certain amount of percentage and then
after that it's no longer copyright 30
yeah 30 so like you know you could
algorithmically take an AI script or a
script give it to an AI and be like hey
rewrite the script the same way change
30 of it but keep the the main story the
same oh yeah so that it's like Falls
within like not being able to be liable
for copyright did you guys see there's a
new South Park episode all about AI it's
about chat gbt and how the kids figured
out they could use Chad gbt to do their
homework and [__] and then the teacher
was like I could just use chat you to
grade this [__] I don't gotta read none
of this
and then like and then like uh I think
Stan learns to use Chad gbt to respond
to text from his girl so he never has to
read them and it just Auto responds with
the perfect response to all her texts so
you could just do whatever he wants and
then uh at the end the episode's [__]
brilliant and then at the very end it
goes this episode is written by chat
nice that's so crazy but now we just
have a I mean I feel like we've always
had a world of people who don't really
think much but now we have even more of
a world or Society who is just so
dependent on something doing everything
for them especially when it comes to
thought yeah you're bumping me out dude
sorry what happens though like who's
responding all right welcome to reality
is it is it like a no responsibility
thing then because like you can get sued
for plagiarism when you copy but if
Chachi BT does it and let's say they
don't change it enough who's getting
sued right the Inception of that yeah
nobody right probably nobody Chad gbt
lawyers coming in
oh my God maybe open AI is that the
group that like put chat gbt out yeah
maybe but I mean I think it's a it's a
really complex new industry it's still
your prompt though so it's like you know
which industry this actually is like a
monumentally shifted is sex robots here
we go because you guys remember the
movie serenity
with uh Nathan Fillion uh David crumbles
plays this character where he's out he's
an introvert he's out by himself but
he's got like two or three sex robots
and that you know when uh the whole um
what is it I mean we all stay home
because of the quarantine yeah yeah and
then to me that's the goal of the one
percent or the one percent
uh everyone's gonna subscribe No One's
Gonna own anything you subscribe to
software scrub your car hey you know
what forget owning a car we're gonna
have uh cars like driverless cars pick
you up stay home so if you stay home and
then the sex robots come in for guys
that are introverts that can't talk to
women or whatever why would they need to
go out they have the sex robot because I
don't know if you guys seen sex robots
lately they look crazy they look crazy I
haven't checked them out lately yeah I
like the one I have at home it's really
nice so try some out yeah and bring them
out I haven't been to that store oh you
haven't okay is it on Colorado
but like you put the AI chip in there
where they can have actual conversations
Beyond like yes no yes master yes slave
and you have regular conversations now
people don't need to they don't need to
leave home I mean isn't that kind of the
same thing as only fans and people
utilizing that but with the robots
though you've got something to touch and
hold on to and snuggle with I know they
think like they don't need to leave the
home but they do need to leave them but
there's a lot of countries they don't
like Japan Korea they don't yeah they do
need biologically need to buy things for
sure for sure for sure you know um and
so I'm jealous they work from home they
work on their computer they don't need
to leave there's food delivery yeah and
then if it gets to the point where
robots deliver the food and then they
talk to them how are you doing today
great
here's your food and if they have the AI
chip in there that's that to me is like
the scary part of it all like the
plagiarism thing as a writer yeah of
course that's huge but to me it's like
this is taking a step back it's the sex
robots that's where that's where we go
on strike for boys procreations will
decrease as well you look at countries
like Japan and Korea where um the birth
rate has gone down and like I think now
India is number one I mean here as well
I mean it's everywhere
um birth rates yeah birth rates
everything or the sex robots you just
keep the nut and then you go make babies
with the robot babies true the nut maybe
maybe the robot baby the robot could
have robot baby I look good on a
billboard did you did you guys see this
one really good observation somebody was
like dude The Jetsons had it backwards
because in the prediction of the future
robots and AI are doing the hard tasks
like the labor but the creative are
still people but it's absolutely the
opposite we still need everybody to do
hard labor and we don't need creative
[__] now isn't that [__] scary yeah
all the art stuff went first but then
still there's a dude in a coal mine yeah
like that's crazy like construction is
still by people you look at the Cobalt
mine like that's crazier than ever
because the prices are too good all the
things that those devices do that
they're mining the battery for yeah
automated what the hell like like Wally
to me the documentary Wally is where
we're headed like documentary technology
is to make our lives easier and Wally is
basically to Pinnacle of that where they
they're done with technology and so they
all got fat because they didn't have to
do anything yeah they're so dependent on
the tools that they created them so I'm
really starting to look like idiocracy
though I hope we go towards that that's
kind of fun no that documentary is fat
shaming so I don't yeah you don't
subscribe
yeah
I just liked it because it you know it's
kind of like has my name in it but
that's not fit okay
well it's just narcissist he's a gas
lighting narcissist that you're like
Wall Street too
[Music]